مجرد مشهد لا يصدق هنا
أندرسون، هناك المئات والمئات
من الكاميرات التي تم توجيهها للتو إلى هذا الباب
حيث يتوقعون أن يدخل الرئيس السابق
محاولًا التقاط تلك اللقطة
له وهو يدخل هذا المبنى ونحن
الآن نرى أه أحد الضباط الأوائل
يصلون  والآن نرى سيارات الدفع الرباعي هنا
تسحب أندرسون وهم
يتوقفون هنا الآن عند
الباب، هل يمكنكم يا رفاق الوقوف للخلف ونرى
العديد من سيارات الدفع الرباعي هنا أندرسون
يتوقف
عند الزاوية والرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب على وشك الخروج  من سيارة
الدفع الرباعي هذه وأدخل مكتب المدعي العام في مانهاتن
حيث سيتم وضعه قيد
الاعتقال وهنا مما لا يمكننا
رؤيته
اثنين من عملاء الخدمة السرية
يخرجون الآن من سياراتهم
هنا في الشارع في مكان هوجان
بالترتيب الأمامي
وها هو
الحشد
هناك، يمكننا رؤيته هنا أندرسون
وظهره لنا ويمكننا رؤيته
ببطء، نعم لدينا لقطة فوق الرأس
التي ننظر إليها الآن
للرئيس السابق وهو يسير مع
العديد من  ضباط الخدمة السرية الخاصة به
يدخلون المبنى
وكارين تقول إنه بمجرد
دخوله هذا المبنى فهو من الناحية الفنية
قيد الاعتقال، نعم،
في عهدة محققي مكتب المدعي العام، ومن
الواضح أنه مع
حارس الخدمة السرية الخاص به أيضًا وسيتم
إخباره بذلك  قيد الاعتقال وهو
محتجز لديهم في هذا الوقت، لذا في هذه
اللحظة الساعة 1:24 مساءً بالتوقيت الشرقي،
يكون دونالد جي ترامب قيد الاعتقال